hey guys so as we take this right now
President Obama is in Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia is one of our biggest allies in
the Gulf but we actually don't have that
much in common with them especially when
it comes to human rights at least human
rights within the borders of the country
ourselves I know we all every country
does bad things outside of our borders
and sometimes in our borders but I want
to talk about the women's rights issue
because it's really interesting that in
Saudi Arabia right now women cannot
drive
they also legally can't vote supposedly
in 2015 they'll be able to vote except
they can't drive to a polling station
that might be a problem but I don't
wanna be too glib about this and I did
tweet this morning something about this
and a couple people from Saudi Arabia
did respond to me and they were - that I
thought were particularly interesting so
one person said nobody thinks about such
a ridiculous thing about women driving
we think about innocent people getting
killed every day in Syria in Iraq so I
thought that was one interesting way
it's a sort of deflection and it's not
really talking about the same issue but
I think I think it's something and it's
just trying to get a little insight into
what they're thinking and then this one
I thought was really interesting and
this looks like a kid he looks like he's
about 20 years old he said there are
things that don't need to be equal
including women driving cars there are a
lot of accidents let alone if women
drive now of course it's easy for us you
know I'm gonna let the woman take it
away before I even go any further okay I
don't I'm not one of those people who
thinks that the United States need to
meddle in everyone else's business if if
they have this issue in the country they
need to figure it out for themselves I
don't want to get involved I wanted to I
don't want to tell them hey you should
do this and that but I know what my
opinion is about it and I think it's
stupid like oh we're gonna have more car
accidents of women Drive did you know
that here in the United States women
actually have lower premiums for their
car insurance because they're actually
statistically less likely to crash their
cars right now I'm gonna venture to say
that he doesn't know about all those
things that he's getting different
information but that's partly also
because the government keeps him that
sort of ignorant auntie they keep you
know they keep racial divides and
device based on sex and all that so yeah
I really can't blame you know 20 year
old kid necessarily right or or can you
in an age of yeah look he grew up he
grew up with that anti woman propaganda
or women propaganda and so like I guess
you can't really blame him if that's the
environment that he lives in but I just
what are you gonna do see that's the
thing like what is the United States
supposed to do and just because our
country has done some pretty [ __ ] up
things and work her they're doing [ __ ]
up things yeah doesn't mean that you're
completely immune from doing anything
bad I mean it's very possible that both
countries have serious issues that they
need to work out now I wouldn't want
Saudi Arabia trying to invade United
States or try to tell us what we should
shouldn't do right I don't want their
military getting involved or anything
like that but I mean at the same time
your country has issues you need to work
on it equality is really really
important right and that of course is
the beauty of YouTube and Twitter and
social media and all that which
interestingly as we're doing this right
now speaking of another country in the
area
turkey blocked YouTube this week I know
that is actually insane so there was
actually audio released showing that the
prime minister wanted to do like a false
flag operation yeah and what that means
is they were going to invade either a
Turkish embassy or Turkish property
within Syria and make it seem as though
the Syrians did it so Turkey can invade
or they were gonna make it seem as
though Syria was attacking the country
of Turkey and the reason why they did
that is because at the type of war
usually people will rally in support of
the incumbents sort of like that George
Bush guy with that homework thing yeah
so that's super shady but again like I
just I'm so tired of the United States
getting all involved in all these things
like when it comes to the Middle East
when it comes to any other country I
just feel like look why don't we focus
on keeping our border safe let's focus
on taking care of our own people and let
other countries
for themselves unless their imminent
threats new it's what I used to not
think that way so much but I now have so
little faith in our government like our
ability to govern properly and you see
everything just the way everyone's
fighting constantly that how what right
do we have to tell anyone else anywhere
like you but so I wanted to end this was
what do you think Obama should do
because I do think that's kinda
interesting he's there women's rights
seem to be the most basic human right
they're just like you need some sort of
baseline thing like right we treat our
women the same even if you don't want to
go the gate the gate thing that's still
a bridge too far
creating women yeah I think should be so
should he see anything there's not any
right well I think I think it's okay to
have share your opinion on it but I
think the best way to combat these types
of issues is through education so you go
into these countries with education with
the tools necessary to empower the women
so they can actually defend themselves
and fight for themselves look here in
the United States like women's suffrage
we didn't have another country come in
and tell us hey you need to make sure
that women have the right to vote no it
was a grassroots movement that really
grew here in the United States and that
happened thanks to education and
empowering people so that's the same
thing you can do abroad you don't have
to do it militarily you don't even
necessarily have to do it through
sanctions education is really the key
its power that's the way you change
things well said by one of the smartest
girls I know and a great driver